this right here is Microsoft's 13.5 inch
surface book 3 which replaces the
surface book 2 from 3 years ago and just
by looking at the exterior you would
have no idea that it's the new one since
there are literally no physical changes
at all the size stayed the same the
keyboard stay the same the port's stayed
the same
the hinge design is the same basically
everything is identical between the two
except that the new model has updated
internals so before I talk about all the
changes and how I feel about this laptop
overall I want to show off some of the
highlights or things that I like about
it this is probably one of the most
unique laptops thanks to its hinge which
allows you to detach the display and use
it as a tablet this means that the new
tension Intel processor is built into
the tablet portion but at the same time
the keyboard portion holds an extra
battery and an updated gtx 1650 max-q
graphics card for extra graphics
performance along with that the
magnesium body and the build quality is
great and it really does look like a
nice and premium laptop the display is
nice sharp and color accurate with a
three by two aspect ratio which is great
for web browsing and using it as a
tablet it's got a nice variety of ports
as well and the keyboard is probably one
of the best that i've ever used the
front-facing camera is excellent packin
windows hello for automatic login and it
even has an 8 megapixel camera on the
back it's also nice that you get Wi-Fi 6
connectivity as well so overall it's a
very premium device with up to date
specs and a lot of flexibility to use as
a laptop or as a tablet but my big issue
with this two-in-one is that in the past
three years the competition has gotten
so much better while the surface book
hasn't really changed at all the hinge
hasn't been redesigned or slimmed down
so you still have that gap in between
both portions it's still just as large
and bulky as before the display still
has fairly large bezels there still no
phone
three port and in fact the ports haven't
changed at all and with all of that it's
more expensive than before so Microsoft
basically took the easy route and simply
swapped out a couple of internals and
called it good but let's disregard all
of that and look at it for what it
really is a premium 2 in 1 laptop my
issue with it is that it tries to do a
lot of different things but it doesn't
do one specific thing very well at least
not $2,000 well like for example using
it as a tablet it's light and thin but
the bezels are pretty large especially
if you're trying to watch a video or a
movie the quality and color accuracy of
the display is great but it's very
reflective at the same time it's nice
that it's packing Intel's latest 10 gen
i7 CPU but because the tablet portion is
so thin the performance is greatly
limited to keep the temps down and
extend battery life even the base
macbook pro for $1,300 which packs the
old 8th gen i 5 chip scored around 24%
higher than the surface book 3 in
Cinebench r 20 so this is the lowest
score we've seen from this chip out of
the many laptops we've tested that have
the same i7 processor so it sucks
knowing that if you're wanting to do
something like photo editing or other
cpu dependent work but by far the worst
thing about it is the speakers which are
incredibly quiet compared to everything
else on the market
[Music]
so while you can use the tablet to watch
a movie the speakers are just terrible
so looking at the surface book 3 from a
tablet perspective there are much better
options on the market now if you're
looking at it from a laptop perspective
it's larger in bulkier than the
competition because of the detachable
hinge design and the performance is
worse than much thinner and lighter
laptops that have better speakers and
track pads and I experienced issues
where the keyboard and trackpad would be
unresponsive when reconnecting the
tablet so I'd either have to close and
open the display or disconnect and
reconnect it again to get it to work a
major selling point of the surface books
are the dedicated graphics the gtx 1650
graphics card offers a lot of
performance for getting productivity
work done but because of the two on one
design with the thin tablet the
processors very limited performance is
going to bottleneck the graphics card in
things like video editing graphics
rendering photo editing and more so the
extra graphics power kind of goes to
waste and in terms of using the graphics
card for gaming the 3 by 2 aspect ratio
display isn't a good fit it's pretty
expensive for a gaming laptop and is
only a 60 Hertz display so there are
much better options for gaming even for
those who want a premium laptop like the
Razer Blade stealth 13 or if you just
care about gaming there's a $1,300 HP
omen 15 which comes with a much more
powerful RTX 2060 and a 144 hurst
display in with that laptop you can
actually take off the case and upgrade
everything from the m2 SSD in the ram to
the battery and you even have the option
to add your own two and a half inch SSD
but with the surface book 3 you
literally can't upgrade anything at all
due to the design which was pretty
awesome in 2017 but now in 2020 is just
not that special anymore and if you want
this model with the ice
and the GTX 16:50 graphics card you're
paying $2,000 and only getting a 256 gig
SSD which isn't upgradeable
so basically I've realized that the
market for the surface book 3 is very
small
you'd have to want a large touchscreen
tablet with an x86 processor you'd have
to not care about speaker quality at all
and you'd also have to want a laptop
with a great keyboard and a dedicated
graphics card for limited productivity
work that doesn't need great processor
performance or maybe some gaming on the
side and honestly that's a pretty
specific market and considering how good
the competition has become over the last
three years I have a very hard time
seeing how many people the surface book
3 would be great for we now have the
magic keyboard case for the iPad pro so
if you need a capable tablet that can
also be used as a basic laptop it's
great or if you want a dedicated
graphics card in a small laptop then the
Razer Blade stealth 13 packs all of that
in a smaller and lighter package with
lots of improvements over the years or
if you don't need graphics power the
Dell XPS 13 is also a much better choice
in practically every way and for less
money and even Microsoft's own service
laptop 3 is a great laptop if you want
that 3 by 2 display or if you want to
tablet with an x86 chip there's the
surface pro 7 as well so the surface
book 3 tries to do all of those things
but it's basically a jack of all trades
and a master of none and one with a
pretty big price tag now don't get me
wrong I love the concept of a powerful
GPU in the keyboard portion and having a
detachable tablet but this is a 20-17
product competing in 2020 personally I
wouldn't recommend the service book 3
for most because of the cons far
outweigh the pros and the new components
aren't able to be used to their full
potential because of the two-in-one
design that limits cooling performance
and sacrifices portability it would
been different if Microsoft slimmed it
down or added better speakers or maybe
even lower the price to be more
competitive but they didn't but hey
people are still buying it so if you
chose to buy in the surface book 3 let
us know why you did down in the comment
section below
we want to know how you use it and why
you chose it over the competition
if this review was helpful to you go
ahead and tap the like button and click
the circle above to subscribe thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]